مفهوم اساسي تقوم عليه الانتخابات
التشريعيه الامريكيه يعرف باعاده تقسيم
الدوائر الانتخابيه
ويستند الى تعداد سكاني يجرى كل عشر سنوات
بحيث يكون لكل منطقه ممثل واحد على الاقل
يمثل عدد السكان
اعادته رسم حدود المقاطعات يعني خسارته او
ربح نحوي ثلاثه عشره ولايه لمقاعده في
الكونغرس اعتمادا على التغير السكاني فيها
فبعد التعداد السكاني الاحداث قل عدد
الدوائر التنفسيه بين الاحزاب بشكل عام
واقتصرت على 34 من ثقافه فقط وذلك بما
معدله 17 منطقه اقل من ما كانت عليه عند
استخدام الخرائط السابقه هذه المناطق
السبعه عشره حلت مكانها 9 مقاطعه
الجمهوريه وثمانيه مقاطعه ديمقراطيه
ولاعبت تكساس دورا كبيرا في تراجع المناطق
التنفسيه
فكانت تحويل 11 منطقه لكن جمهوريين اعادوا
رسم الخريطه لتبقى واحده فقط
واثبتت التجارب التاريخيه استفاده الحزب
المسيطر على المجالس التشريعيه في
الولايات من ترسيم الدوائر الانتخابيه
وبالفعل سيطرته مجالس تشريعيه ذات اغلبيه
الجمهوريه على نحوي 30 ولايه اعطتهم
الكلمه الاخيره بشان اعاده تقسيم الدوائر
في 170 دائره
بينها الاسكا ومونتانا وفرنس لا تتبعوا
قوانين اعاده تقسيم الدوائر لامتلاكها
ممثلا واحدا فقط
[موسيقى]